ya hemos hablado sobre las integrales
definidas como la integral definida de a
ave de fx de x esto representa el área
bajo la curva fx este es el eje y este
el eje x esta curva es igual a fx si
esto es a y esto es b podemos pensar que
esta expresión es igual a esta área pero
qué pasa si la función no se encuentra
por arriba del eje x y estuviera por
debajo de éste vamos a dibujar este
escenario donde la función eje x está
así esto es igual a gd x aquí está y
aquí esta vez también digamos que esta
área de acá es igual a 5 si nos
preguntaran cuál es la integral definida
de a a b de gx de x cual piensan que
será la respuesta quizá se vean tentados
a decir que es el área entre la curva y
el eje x es decir que es igual a 5 pero
aquí debemos ser cuidadosos porque si
nos interesa el área por arriba de la
curva y por debajo del eje x
el lugar del área bajo la curva y arriba
del eje x esta integral definida será
igual al negativo del área más adelante
veremos que aunque esto funciona muy
bien para todo un conjunto de
propiedades de la integral si queremos
comprender un poco el por qué se da esto
pensemos en una gráfica de velocidad
contra tiempo el eje horizontal es el
tiempo y el eje vertical es la velocidad
las unidades de velocidad son metros por
segundo y el tiempo está en segundos de
hecho vamos a dibujar dos escenarios
tenemos una primera gráfica de velocidad
contra tiempo que llamaremos b1 dt que
es igual a tres metros por segundo por
lo que luce así a que será igual la
integral definida desde el tiempo igual
a uno al tiempo igual a cinco debe sub
uno
dt dt pues aquí la función está por
arriba del eje horizontal así que de 1 a
5 tenemos esta área de acá esta área es
3 metros por segundo multiplicada por 4
segundos que es el cambio en el tiempo
por lo que el área es de 12 metros esto
lo podemos interpretar como el cambio en
la posición
la velocidad es tres metros por segundo
y como es positiva podemos decir que va
a la derecha cuál es el cambio en la
posición pues es de 12 metros a la
derecha no necesitamos saber cálculo
para encontrar esto tres metros por
segundo multiplicado por cuatro segundos
es igual a 12 metros pero qué pasaría si
esto fuera al revés si tenemos una
función en velocidad de sub 2 dt que es
igual a menos 2 metros por segundo
aquí dibujamos b sub 2 dt cuál debería
ser la integral definida de 15
dv sub 2 de t dt pues debe ser igual al
cambio en la posición pero si la
velocidad es negativa entonces significa
que el movimiento es a la izquierda por
lo que el cambio en la posición también
es a la izquierda en lugar de a la
derecha vemos esta área de acá y vemos
que es 2 x 4 igual a 8 pero debemos
tener cuidado porque el área está debajo
del eje horizontal y por arriba de la
función así que esto será negativo esto
tiene sentido porque si el movimiento es
2 metros por segundo
recordemos que el signo negativo indica
la dirección a la izquierda y esto
ocurre durante 4 segundos entonces el
cambio en la posición será 8 metros a la
izquierda que expresamos con el signo
negativo esto es igual a menos 8 en
resumen si el área de la integral está
por debajo de la función y por arriba
del eje horizontal ya es menor que b
entonces la integral definida es
positiva si es menor que b y el área de
la integral está por arriba de la
función y por debajo del eje horizontal
entonces la integral definida es
negativa más adelante veremos integrales
que son una mezcla de ambas lo que es un
poco más complicado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo